Hello everyone, and welcome to another end
game video. We are starting to move toward
the end of, uh, the section on Pawn Endgame's.
Uh, time just seems to fly. I can't believe
it's already been something like four videos.
In the previous video, we talked about using
Your King effectively. And today we are going
to explore six • • more advanced, but
no less crucial Pawn Endgame concepts. These
are six concepts that don't necessarily neatly
fit into some sort of basic category, like
opposition or Zugzvang. They're a little bit
more involved, they're going to take a little
bit more explaining. But I'm going to try
to do it as I usually do, in an accessible
and understandable way, even if you're not
all that experienced upon endgame. So don't
be afraid of the word advanced. And, uh, as
per usual, make sure your desk is clear, your
phone is off, you've brewed a nice cup of
tea or coffee, and well, without further ado,
let's delve in. And actually, before we do,
i, uh, will point out that this is going to
be the final sort of conceptual Pawn Endgame
video in the next video. The final video on
Pawn endgames. For now, we're, uh, going to
put everything together. I'm going to give
you a set of ten positions, uh, to solve on
your own. And then we're going to go through
the solutions, uh, on the video. And, uh,
these ten positions are going to hit on all
of the concepts that we have covered in, uh,
the conceptual video. So we're going to do
sort of a large scale review. And I will give
you ample, uh, • opportunities to really
put everything to the test and make sure that,
uh, you've mastered all of the crucial concepts.
OK? So let's now jump in. And much like the
Pawn Race video, rather than having a definition
section and then a Practicum section, uh,
because these concepts are a little bit more
advanced, they don't necessarily lend themselves
to, uh, just kind of a dry definition. So,
uh, I'm going to give you the definition,
but I'm going to do it, ah, through the lens
of the, uh, actual games. We're going to jump
straight into the, uh, practical section.
And, uh, because of that, we're going to spend
a little bit longer on each position. So I'm
still going to try to clearly explain what
each concept refers to, but we're going to
go straight into the, uh, analysis. I just
think that will be a little bit more practical.
And, uh, like in the pottery meet, I'm going
to project the definition over on the top
left. Uh, hopefully that technology, • • • uh,
will work. And that way you can consistently
refresh your memory and remind yourself of
what the overarching theme is, uh, for each
example that we look at. Now, in our first
example, we're going to review • • a concept
that we touched on in the previous video on
Using Your King. We talked extensively about
waiting moves. A waiting move is a pawn move
that you make, uh, in order to pass the turn
to your opponent frequently with the aim of
inducing zoogzbang. Zoogzbang, you might remember,
is a situation in which any move that a side
can make harms their position or usually leads
to a loss or an undesirable result. So there
is a sort of subconscious within waiting,
the realm of waiting moves that I, uh, want
to hammer home. And I think this example is
just great. Overall, there's tons, uh, • of
cool stuff here. You might recognize the player
who has the white pieces, henry Grob. That
is the very same Grob who developed the opening
named after him, won G Four. No comment on
that. G Four has been in the news a lot lately.
Magnus Carlson has played at Ikaro. Both of
them have played, I think, to win a title
Tuesday. But, uh, Grab was also a pretty darn
strong player. He was a master, I think, from
Sweden. And in this game, he faces another
very strong master, hungarian Laos Steiner.
And we are going to face, • uh, Steiner's
side. So, rule number one, concept number
one is the waiting move sacrifice. Uh, which
is the process of giving away a pawn in order
to generate an additional waiting move. Now,
you're like, Well, I can read that, too. Can
you remind me what exactly that means? And
that's exactly what I'm going to do with this
example. • • • Um, now, for starters,
let's begin with some general observations.
Who's playing for a win? What can we notice
in this position? If you watched the previous
video carefully, you will know that you should
focus on a couple of things right off the
bat. Who's king is more active? Who's got
the capacity to create past pawns? And perhaps
most importantly, who has how many waiting
moves? Now, neither side has a past pawn for
the time being. Black is the only one who
can create a past pawn with the move at five.
We'll get to that in a second. It does appear
that black sking is more active. Blacks King
is on the fifth rank, white's King is on the
third rank, and might even conceivably get
pushed away further down the board. So it
seems pretty obvious that black is the one
playing for a win, especially because if you
count up the waiting moves, white kind of,
sort of has one way to move the move, g Four.
But G Four actually allows black skin to infiltrate
a four. So it's like a semi waning move. Black
is the only one with two pure waiting moves.
There's, ah, a six and a five. Before we start
analyzing, I remind you of something very
important from the previous video. If you
have waiting moves almost all of the time,
you want to be economical with your waiting
moves. If you have two of them, you don't
want to exhaust both of them. At the same
time, you want to save as many winning moves
as possible for a rainy day, because sometimes
you have to induce Zubesbang more than once
as you try to outmaneuver your opponent's
resilient king. So • • the first step,
of course, is to consider the tempting move
F Five. Now, from, uh, the earlier videos,
you, uh, might remember that when you have
a situation where both sides have passed pawns,
you want to see who has the outside past pawn,
the past pawn that is furthest away from all
of the other pawns. And unfortunately, although
Black creates a passport here, you're also
giving White a passer. And this Jeep on is
an outside passer. White is actually completely
winning here by distracting Black's king and
then walking, uh, his own king over to the
Queensland, capturing all of our pawns. This
is clearly, clearly no good. White's gonna
play king e four. And, you know, black is
black is blessed. So we can't break through
directly with F Five. That means we're going
to have to adopt a more subtle method. We're
going to have to try to shoulder White's king
off of F Three and somehow infiltrate our
way, uh, to the king side. So, as always,
pause the video and see if you can figure
out a way of doing that, trying to calculate
as deeply as you can. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • All
right, so I think the first move is • • pretty
straightforward. Now, • • if you want
to make a waiting move, your default should
be to wait with your king, right? If you can
avoid spending a pawn waiting move, then you
should. And I think a lot of people would
think, oh, let's play a six. It's the right
concept. But here you're exhausting a waiting
move. You can do exactly the same thing, but
by moving your king over to the side, king
H Five is the only correct first move. And
the reason this works is because while White
still has to move his king back, the, uh,
move, G Four, allows king H Four. And here,
White is immediately in Zubesbangg and loses
the game. So Grob plays king back to F Two,
and, uh, this is a very sensible move. Now
black advances to G four. So we've made some
progress. But White steps into the opposition,
and Black can make no further progress with
his king. But this is where the waiting moves
come in so handy. And Steiner, a student of
the endgame, he watched our videos, not just
getting this game was played, I think, in
the 1950s. But he knows about being economical
with his weighting moves, and so he correctly
plays a six rather than a five. This forces
White's King off of G two. Now, which way
is Grob going to go? Well, if he goes to H
Ah Two, then Black wins on the spot with king
F three. That's obvious. White plays the move.
King f two. And here it looks like uh, • we've
succeeded. The black king now infiltrates
to age three. But it's not just enough to
say, oh, well, now I've infiltrated, you actually
have to make progress with your king. And,
uh, in the previous movies, we've seen some
examples where, yes, you infiltrate, but then
you hit some sort of a dead end. And once
again, • • uh, it may appear that White
steps into opposition with king F three, and
Black cannot make any progress. The kings
just keep dancing around between H one, H
two, and H three. But no, no, no. This is
where the second waiting move comes in handy.
With the white king on F two, the best move
is now a five, putting White in a second zoobs
bomb. Now, remember, if White pushes the pawn,
you revert back to the initial idea. You just
bring your king back to H four. And we've
already seen this zoogzbon before. White loses
the pawn. • • But if White plays king
F three, which is the only other move, then
you shoulder the king from behind. We play
the move king to G one, and you continue to
push White's king out of the king side. Again,
if White plays G four, you just come back
to actually, no, here, you don't come back
to H I apologize here. Um, • • • • and
we will see almost an identical scenario unfold
in, uh, the game. So let's, uh, pause this
line for now, because the way Grub played,
uh, leads to essentially exactly the same
position. Uh, • • • so after king G
one, in fact, G four is really the only feasible
move here, because, uh, if White does anything
else, if White plays king G three, then Black
wins elementarily with king G two and king
G three. If White plays king G four, then
this is also very easy. We step into the opposition
king F five, we take the pawn, king takes
F six. And hopefully you were able to calculate
up to this point where Black wins the pawn
on E four and then promotes, uh, the ePawn.
But Henry Grubb, he calculates all this, and
he says, I don't want to cooperate. I don't
want to let my opponent put me in loops on.
So he decides to play the move A five. He
sacrifices a pawn in order to deprive Black
of his second waiting movement. After B takes
a five, king F three, is it now time to panic?
We don't have any more waiting moves. We can't
make any progress with our king. That's it.
Aim is drawn. Well, no, it's not. And that's
where our first advanced concept comes in
handy. We have seen that already in the previous
video. If your opponent does something like
this, if you have doubled pawns, you can usually
give the front pawn away in order to regenerate
that waiting move which you need so desperately.
So Mr. Steiner, he plays King H two, king
F Two. Although you could play this, what
uh, he's about to do immediately with the
king on H three. Doesn't matter. He gives
away the pawn with a four. White has to take
it. And now here comes the second waiting
move, a five. This is a ubiquitous method.
You're almost always going to have this if
your opponent plays a move like a five. And
now White is once again in Zugzpong. Grab
plays King F. Three. Steiner plays King G
one. And here, as we were discussing, grab
plays the most resilient move. He plays g
four. This is a super resilient resource.
And actually, not only does Black have only
one winning move, black has to find this move
in order not to lose. So, once again, pause
the video, make sure that you figure out where
Black's king should go, and try to calculate
until the end of the line. Figure out what
Grob is up to with this move, g four. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • So
the tempting move and the move that I almost
recommended by my mistake is king back to
H two. And you might say, well, king f two,
king h three, king f three, king h four We've
seen this a million times by now. Why isn't
Zookspot but clearing the pathway? G five.
And white wins the game. This is Grub's idea,
and hopefully you were able to spot this.
F takes g five. King g four. Now, Black skin
is the one that gets shouldered, and White
king reaches the EPON first and wins in exactly
the same way that we just saw Black winning.
So crowd was just a devilish idea. And so
Black has to maneuver a lot more astutely
the correct move. Here is king F One continuing
the shoulder shouldering process. • • • • Grob,
of course, has to play G five. If he steps
away with his king, the shouldering gets complete.
King G three, king E two or king E three?
King g. Two is easy. And after g five f g
king g four. Steiner was able to calculate
this out correctly until the final Zoo Zwany,
he plays king E Two. • • White has to
take on G five. If you say, well, I learned
in the pawn race video that you shouldn't
take any unnecessary pawns. Let's start racing.
After king F five. • Uh, • • • the
simplest win is just king F. Uh oh, actually,
here you can just take the pawn. And here,
black wins the pawn race, uh, by a tempo.
So that doesn't work. White has to play king
takes G five. And now Black plays king T three,
king F five and King D four. This is a very
famous zoo zone. You see this particular type
of Zigzag in a lot of different end games.
These other ponds are just window dressing.
What you should really be focused on are the
EPA's and the way that the kings are positioned.
I think there might even be a name for this,
but, um, I don't remember. The point is, white
isn't zoom's on the king, can't keep in contact
with the E four pawn and Henry Grubb. This
is move 109, a heroic effort by Steiner. He
resigned in this position because once he
moves his king away, black captures on e four
steps away and promotes the ePawn. So the
crazy thing is that this is like tempo for
tempo. Once you started the shouldering process,
black was at risk of losing the game if he
had miscalculated. And so, apart from our
first concept, uh, really the gloom of what
made everything tick was this a four, a five
sacrifice without which Black would have been
able to make no progress at all. But in addition,
you can just see the importance of calculating
these types of end games out until the very
end, until the final zoosong. There's three
separate Zoog songs that you have to put right
in in order to make progress. The first one
comes here. You make it to the fourth rank.
Then another zoogzwong number two, you make
it to the third rank. Actually, no four zoom
zwan. The third one is here. • • Finally,
you get to the first rank, and then the final
one occurs in the final position after king
T four. But the key takeaway, when you have
double pawns, you can give one of them away
in order to regenerate that extra weighting.
Move on we go to concept number two. And here
I'm going to make an exception to my sort
of general rule about not showing famous games.
The game that I'm about to show is in fact
super famous. But I think it's famous for
a very good reason. And we have to pay tribute
to a Kiba Rubenstein. Search on Wikipedia,
read about him. One of the strongest players
of, uh, the 20th century, and I love Rubenstein.
He really developed a lot of the positional
concepts that we take for granted. Now, his
positional understanding for the early 1900s
was off the charts. He never became world
champion, but he beat all of the top players
of the day, allocon topoblanca, et cetera,
many, many times over. His weakness, though,
was tactics. If he was a little bit better
at tactics, I think he would be world champion.
Super talented player. And this endgame is
one of his best. So concept number two. Let
me • • perform this very high tech • • maneuver,
uh, • • here with my Word document. Close
number one. And at the end, I'm going to display
all of them. So don't really worry about,
uh, taking all of it down • • immediately.
Uh, • • • • I call this mowing the
lawn. And I refer to, uh, mowing the lawn
as a trade of ponds that, uh, obstructs the
pathway to a weak pond or a set of ponds which
are often located on the other side of the
board. You're like, Holy smokes. This reminds
me of my days in college when I read a philosophy
paper. What does this say? Let me read that
again, mowing the lawns involves trading a
pawn or a set of pawns that are obstructing
a path that your king can take to a certain
set of other pawns that you wish to attack.
And this, I think you can see why, is the
reason why I am trying to illustrate these
examples directly illustrate, uh, • • these
concepts directly with an example, because
many of them are just much easier to understand
if you actually see this thing in action.
Now, Mark Dortzky, in his endgame manual,
refers to this technique as widening the beachhead.
I did not know what a beach head was. I had
to look it up. A beach head, apparently, is
a military line that's set up on, uh, a beach,
and then you can kind of understand • • • what
it means to widen it. But I like to invent
fun names for things. So hopefully you'll
appreciate, uh, the • • analogy here with
mowing the lawn. So what the heck does this
mean? You're like, I want to see this in action.
• • • Mowing the lawn. What is that?
So let's look in this position. Yes. This
is not opponent game just yet, but Eric Kohn,
Urban Stein's opponent, plays a very instructive
mistake. He plays him with rooks he won, offering
a rook trade that Black cannot refuse. If
you refuse this trade, then White infiltrates
the 7th rank. So Rubenstein says, well, I'm
going to take on C one. And the first thing
Akuba Rubenstein does is apply • • one
of the rules from our previous video on using
your king. He charts a course. And this is
a perfect illustration of charting a course
because it isn't immediately clear where Blacks
king should go. Do you go toward the center?
Do you go to the kingside? How do you not
get overwhelmed in this situation? Well, uh,
I mentioned in the last video that when you're
charting a course, you should start by trying
to figure out what your opponent's most accessible
and most significant pawn weakness is. Does
your opponent have any, maybe isolated pawns
that can be attacked with your king? Well,
if I put it that way, you should immediately
see that there, in fact, is an isolated pawn
on H two, and Black's King has a direct pathway
to that pawn. You can play king F six and,
uh, then OOH. And I think I might not have
had, uh, the move sounds enabled, but let
me enable them now. • • • Hopefully
not not too big of a deal. Uh, but you have
a direct pathway to Zappawn on H two. It just
only takes you a couple of moves to get there.
You might also notice that if you try to get,
uh, to the queen side via the center, white's
not just going to • • sit, uh, around.
Oh, uh, no, not I. He's just going to bring
his king up to D three, and we are at a dead
end. White has plenty of squares that he can
just toggle between, uh, • with his king.
So there's no chance of inducing zoosong here.
And so I'll give Ruinstein begins by advancing
his king, charting a course, and walking his
king over to age three. Now, Cohen saw this.
Of course he saw this, and he is able to get
his own king just in time. Tempo for tempo
to G one. And this, I think, is where • • Rubenstein's,
uh, • • opponent stopped calculating.
He figured that he's just going to move his
king between H one and G one for all of affinity.
And how on earth is Black going to make progress
the moment black king steps back from H four?
Well, white king follows him in turn, and
only white is the one making progress here.
What on earth does black do in order to try
to win this game? Uh, this is where we see
the concept of mowing a lawn or widening the
beachhead in action. And I think this is the
finest illustration of this concept that I
have seen. Pause the video, take a sip of
a coffee, figure out what Black's plan is.
And my recommendation here is to focus less
on the individual moves and more on your target
position, what it is that you want to achieve
in the end. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • So
in order to understand Rubenstein's mo here,
• • uh, let's break this down conceptually.
What do we see? Well, we see pawns on either
side of the board. There's kingside pawns,
and there are queen side ponds. Now, of course,
we also see the black king is incomparably
more active than its visa vis. So imagine
a scenario where all of the ponds just magically
disappeared from the kingside. All of them
disappeared from the kingside. What would
happen in that situation for a black to move?
Well, just imagine that in your head, right?
No pawns on the king side. Well, black would
probably walk the king over to the queenside,
right? King G three, and then king F three,
and then king E three, et cetera, et cetera.
And white's king would only be able to follow
on the first rank up until the black king
reaches B three. Actually. Hey, I just opened
Chess Base. I am just going to I wasn't planning
this, but I'm going to set this up to help
people visualize this, because I think it
is a very important concept, and there's going
to be a really cool trick, a really cool caveat
here. So you, uh, might notice that what I'm
about to say right now isn't strictly correct
in, uh, one particular regard, but, you know,
stay tuned. So all of the pawns are gone from,
• • • • uh, • • the kingside,
and then we would get the following position
analysis board. Let's paste it in. We would
get the oop. Of course, it's chess Pieces
is throwing an error. Let's see. All right,
there we go. • • • • • No, it's
not. • • • • This is working every
time up until I actually • • • needed
to work. • • Um, • • • • • • yes,
I don't know why it's not, ah, • • letting
me, uh, try let me try • • saving, um,
• this as a PGN. And if that doesn't work,
then we'll just have to do the visualization
your header. We can set it up on a board.
There we go. Now it works. So • • • • it's
black to play, right? Well, if it's black
to play, the wind is very elementary. Just
here and then here, and then here, and then
here. And then you just get to be three. And
then you just win both of, uh, white's pawns.
Hopefully that helps you visualize the target.
Now we go back to the position on the board,
and let's flip the board. • • Of course,
that might be the target position, but there
are a gazillion ponds on the kingside, and
this is where we can mow the lawn. We can
use our own ponds to trade off as many of
White's ponds as possible in order to open
up the pathway to the other side of the board
where are contained white's weak pawns. Now,
as it turns out, in practice, the plan has
a little bit of a modification. Where Rubenstein
actually does is he trades three of White's
pawns and leaves one of those pawns intact.
And the pawn that he leaves intact is actually
the pawn that he, uh, will end up winning.
So let's watch how he does that. He starts
with the move. E five. • • And that is
not the only move. You could really start
with a bunch of different moves, but this
is as good as any. And the reason I like this
move is because it immobilizes. It deep freezes
in a way. White's entire pawn, majority • • white
cannot play A four because you just take it
and drop your king back. So this is a clinical
way to start. And I like Rubenstein's next
move, too. He now plays B Five, because this
isn't going to hurt, right? Depreasing white's
queenside, pods definitely isn't going to
hurt. You're also depriving white of a waiting
move. Who knows, maybe that'll come in handy
later. As it turns out, it actually does.
So B Five, one of those moves that you can
really play without calculating too much.
You can kind of bet that this move is going
to turn out well for you. • • Cohen has
nothing he can do other than to move his king
back and forth. And now Rubenstein continues
to advance his pawns. He plays F Five, and
after king H One, he very patiently brings
yet another pawn up to G Five. Now, you might
say, why isn't he mowing the lawn? Let's go.
E four. Well, you don't need to rush with
this move, right? This move isn't going anywhere.
Because if White plays E four, then White's
just doing black's work for him. Black actually
wants to trade this pawn, as you'll see. So
there's no rush. Rubenstein brings all four
of his fonts up to the fifth ranking H One.
And only now this he began the actual process
of mowing the lawn. He plays the move G four.
The move E four was equally possible. I mean,
these moves basically transpose into each
other. Uh, we will get this exact position
in the game. So there's multiple ways of achieving
this. He plays G four, the mowing process
begins with the trade of the Ethree pond.
Now, Ericone played the response e four. We'll
get to that in a moment. What would happen
if White obliged if I traded on G four? Well,
• • uh, there's multiple winning methods
here, but the most consistent one, the one
that • • • • most clearly illustrates
the concept of mowing one, is F takes G four.
White again has nothing he can do other than
king G one. Now it is worthwhile to advance
our pawn to E four, once again, deep freezing
the F two pawn. And now the mowing process
continues. H four, king G one, and the crucial
move, G three. This now forces White to trade
all of the pawns HD three, HG three. And after
FG three, king G three, the mowing process
is complete. And here you can see what I was
saying, right? Technically, the pond that
we're actually trying to win now is the E
three pond. And there's actually a very interesting
reason for that. As you will see, if the pawn
on E three and the pond E four were gone,
it would actually not be winning for, uh,
Black, which sounds pretty crazy. • • But,
um, we'll get to that. We'll get to that shortly.
So let's take a rain check on that one. Of
course, as you can see, black just wins E
three and wins the game. If White tries to
play E four, • • this will lead to, uh,
essentially the position from the game. So,
hopefully the concept is becoming a little
bit clearer in the game. After G four, cone
responds with E four. Um, prosaic trap obviously
do not take on F three and allow White to
promote upon Rubenstein and trades on E four
and continues the mowing process age four
and G three. And the, uh, important thing
here is that • • if White tries to play
H takes G three, h take G three, cone resigns
in this position. If White plays F three and
says, I'm not letting you get to the king
side while Black just goes G two. This is
where depriving White of the winning move
really comes in handy because now White is
in zugzvan king F two, king H two wins for
Black. And if White tries a breakthrough,
hey, I'm promoting my pond. Hopefully you
can see that this is a paper tiger king G
three. And this is a classic idea that you
should be familiar with. Mate with two pawns
and a, uh, king. If you really want to throw
your opponent, play them with a six here,
but not, uh, recommended. I didn't tell you
that. So • • there's just. Nothing that
white can do. If White plays king F one, then
there are two ways to win. You can take on
G two on F two, and shoulder the, um, • • white
king. But the clinical method is G two. Check.
King G one. And this is worth saving, that
waiting. Move again and again. You can see
that concept coming in handy. A six induces
zoosvong. F three king steps into G three.
Is this stalemate? No, it's not, because White
still has pawn moves. We talked about this
in the previous video. A four. B takes a four.
And after B five a three. Black promotes first,
and Black promotes, uh, with a queen and with
checkmate more trolling. You can actually
make a bishop in this position. You can actually
make a bishop in this position and then checkmate
on C four. But again, I wouldn't recommend
these things, because once in a blue moon,
they will backfire. Um, so go ahead and make
a queen and deliver. Checkmate. Kohn resigned
after H ah takes G three, because if he takes
on G three, then much like with the pawns
shifted, one square forward doesn't matter,
because Black picks up the pond and E four,
and then uses the E five pond as a decoy and
takes, uh, • care of the remaining queenside
pond. So that's really all that mowing the
lawn, is it's? Engineering a series of pawn
trades in order to clear a pathway for your
king, uh, to access a weakness or a set of,
uh, weaknesses. It's hopefully pretty straightforward.
• • Now, • • um, you might remember
that I mentioned something weird about it
being a draw if, uh, there weren't a set of
epons, like, what is all that about? Again,
hold the thought, because for me to illustrate
that, we, uh, need to talk about, uh, our
third concept. And our third concept is what
I refer to as moving your opponent's pawns.
Let's do the procedure again. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • All
right, cool. So, moving your Opponent's Pawns,
uh, refers to one or multiple pawn sacrifices
that are aimed at shifting your opponent's
pawns in a favorable direction. Now, sacrifices
in pawn endgame's should be nothing new to
you, right? The most common type of sacrifice
is, of course, the breakthrough. And we've
talked about breakthroughs in a separate video.
But that's not the only reason why you would
sacrifice a pawn. There's a more advanced
reason, and that is, uh, what I refer to as
moving your opponent's pawns in, uh, the direction
that is favorable to you. Now, what is a favorable
direction entail? What does that mean? Well,
again, the, uh, easiest way to illustrate
this is with, uh, • a position. And this
actually, I forgot to label this, but this
is a study. This is a composed position by,
uh, Herman Madison, who was not like the president.
I think it's Matt. T-I-S-O-N um he, ah, was
a Latvian master and a very prolific study.
He composed some brilliant positions, and
this is one of them. Love this position. As
an illustration of this concept, it is White
to play and draw the game white is trying
to draw. Pause the video and see what you
can come up with here. And note that is not
a slip of the tongue. Even though you can
take the pawn on G five, your first step is
to figure out why it is White rather than
Black who's trying to make a draw here? M.
• • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • All
right, so hopefully you were able to figure
out that White is inevitably going to lose
both of his pawns. Whichever way you capture
on G five, black is either going to play king
H five and take both pawns like that, or Black
is going to play king H five, king G four,
and eliminate the pawns on F four and G five.
So we're screwed either way right now. How
do we even go about starting to think here?
Well, it's hard to solve this problem unless
you're familiar with the rudiments of king
and pawn versus king endgame. So we're not
going to delve into that right now. The bottom
line is that if you're on the defending side,
if you're the side of the king, you want your
opponent's pawn to be as far along as possible.
The worst case scenario is one in which, uh,
the enemy king is very, very far into your
territory and the pawn is very far behind
because that gives your opponent waiting moves,
and it gives him the possibility to unroll
the red carpet. So the correct first move
is actually H takes G Five, • • um, F
takes G five, loses after getting H five,
and there's just nothing you can do with your
pawns. Black will eliminate both of them.
And this is indeed a worstcase scenario. You
can say, oh, I get the opposition. It's a
draw. It's not a draw. Black has that waiting
move F six, and hopefully you know the procedure
kingd three, king G four. • • There will
later be a separate video on theoretical endgame.
So if you're pretty hazy about this, don't
worry, don't feel bad. You can set this up
and figure this out with an engine, uh, for
now. But you can take my word for it. This
is winning for Black, uh, • • • through
relatively conventional means. So what we
would like is a situation like this, except
for with Black spawn somehow already on F
five. But Black is not going to push the pod
to have five. We have to make him do it. And
this is where the concept comes in handy.
So after H 65 check, • • black will play
king H five. And here the critical moment
occurs. • • You might notice that White
has a rather, uh, interesting idea. We could,
uh, for example, make a king move king G two,
and after a king G four, we could move our
opponent's pawn by playing G six. This is
not a breakthrough. We're just stacking our
pawn to get Black spawn closer, as close as
possible to, uh, the front line. Unfortunately,
Black spawn is now not close enough. You could
try another sacrifice. You could play f five.
But as it happens, after she takes f five,
uh, darn. The kings are already in opposition.
White is the one with, uh, zoos on, but we're
actually getting somewhere. If it was Black
to move here, then we actually have succeeded.
If it was Black to move here, it would be
a draw. The pawn is close enough to the enemy
king. So can we modify this idea in order
to make it Black to move in that position?
Well, as it turns out, the only way to do
that is to immediately start with the move.
G Six is a brilliant idea. If the king takes,
then, well, this is easy. We can just defend
the pawn with our king. We will lose the pawn.
Black will play F six here and shoulder our
king. Actually, no, we won't even have to
lose the pawn. Play. King E three. King G
four. King E four. And if Black plays F five,
you'll notice, uh, the similarity with that
previous grob example. White actually wins
here, so Black has to give up the punt. So
that's not, uh, interesting. And so, of course,
Black will play fake G six. And here is the
critical moment. If you allow king G four,
you lose. You have to sacrifice the second
fawn immediately. We play a five using the
concept a second time, moving Black's pawn
onto the same file as the king. And now we
are able to make a draw not by moving the
king up to G Two or H two. These are mind
squares. And, uh, we will develop a more formal
term for them very shortly. If you play either
of these moves, you allow Black to step into
opposition. Instead, you wait around with
King G one. And now Black cannot cross the
fourth rank, because if he does, you are the
one who steps into opposition with a draw.
King G four, king G two, king H four, king
H two or King G five. We keep chillin. We
play king f one, king f four, king f two.
If Black plays King H four again, we play
KF two. Notice diagonal opposition. And it
is here, as it usually is, a means to an end.
King G four, King G two. Whichever way you
slice it, white is the one who steps into
opposition. And there's just nothing that
Black can do. You hold the first strength
until Black crosses the fourth rank with his
king or with his pawn, after which the pawn
is in front of the king. And then it's really
easy. Uh, at this point, it really doesn't
even matter who has, uh, • opposition. And
this constitutes the notion of moving your
opponent's pawns, sacrificing your own pawns
to shift your opponent's pawns favorably.
Now you might say, well, this is a composition.
Can you show me a reallife example of somebody
doing this? I absolutely can. And this is
where we are going to move to. Should have
rewinded that, but that's okay. This is, we're
going to combine two of, uh, the previous
concepts together. Mowing the lawn and moving
your opponent's pawns. There's a backstory
behind this game that's really cool. This
is a game between two strong grandmasters,
hilar Person and Marcus Ragger, who's close
to 2700. This was played in 2015 in a tournament
in Denmark. I was playing at that tournament.
I remember this game happening. It was a pretty
nondescript game. It wasn't like a super fun
game or anything. I finished my game pretty
early and then I went back to my hotel and
then I was looking through the games from
the round and I looked through this game and
something really, really weird happened at
the end of this game. Well, what happened
at the end of this game? Well, to unlock that,
let's figure out how Marcus Ragher attempted
to win this position with the Black pieces.
And it goes without saying that black is playing
for a win just because of Black's immense
• • advantage, uh, • • in king activity.
Now you might notice the similarity between
the Rubenstein game in this game. Once again,
we have a set of pawns on the queenside that
Black would love to have a turnout with his
king. Unfortunately, there are pawns that
are obstructing the pathway of the king. And
if you play king F four, • uh, then White
will move up to F three. Actually, I apologize,
it is White to move here and white played
the move before. Deep freezing, deep freezing
black spawns and depriving black of waiting
moves on the queenside. • • • So, uh,
now the fact remains, king F four, white plays
king F two and you just aren't able to make
it to the queenside in time. King E three,
kingd uh, five, kingdom three. But here is
where mowing, uh, the lawn comes in handy.
Black can actually get rid of these pawns,
but you have to do it in a very specific way.
You can't just get rid of them nonchalantly,
uh, • • • you have to do it while maintaining
the superiority of your king placement, right?
If your king ends up in Timbuktu by the end
of the mowing lawn operation, then you're
not going to be able to access the queen side
ponds, uh, at all. So Ragger starts by playing
f five. White has no choice but to wait around
with king G one. Now black initiates the process
G four, forcing the trade ftax G four. Now
an important moment FX G four would be wrong
because you are no longer going to be able
to trade the last pair of ponds. White place
king f one. And whichever way black goes,
white claims opposition. King H two, king
F two, and here, actually, white wins after
king G three • • because you can assure
this, uh, you can confirm this yourself, but
White, uh, gets to black's pawns first. So
this would backfire. • • • • Remember
from the previous video, shouldering isn't
always good. Shouldering is something that
has to be undertaken very carefully. You have
to make sure that you actually are going to
benefit from it by being closer to the, uh,
other set of pawns. If black goes king F four,
well, then White plays actually not king F
two. Very instructive moment here. Black plays
G three and gets the opposition. Nope. White
plays King E two using the fact that white
has this waiting move. If black goes king
E four, white executes the move and we have
a dead draw with the kings dancing, uh, around.
Just notice all of these nuances and subtleties.
This is why you have to take your time in
pond end games. And like I said, opposition.
It's not a cure all. You shouldn't get opposition
every chance you can. You have to actually
contextualize, • uh, • • you have to
make specific observations about the position
at hand. Pawn end games are devilish. So instead,
Ragger takes back with the king. Now, the
pawns are on adjacent files, which means that
they can be traded. White steps in to F two.
And this is where the sort of main part of
Black's idea comes in. You play the move F
four. This is a waiting move. But it also
happens to be part of the plan, right? You're
advancing the pawn to F three. You're forcing
Whites gang back. Where are you forcing it
back to either the first rank or the second
rank. It doesn't matter because we're going
to get the same position. And here something
crazy happened. The notation ended and I was
like, there's no way the game ends here. Later,
uh, I figured out the game did end here. Hilar
person resigned. He put his king down in this
position. He and RAGAR both assumed that the
mowing lawn operation was a success and that
there was nothing White could do. What made
them make this assumption? Well, it was the
following variation. Whichever way white goes,
black will go king G three. For example, let's
say king E two, king G three, king F one and
we complete the mowing the lawn operation
with f three, much like Rubenstein did trading
the last pair of pawns. And Black will simply
make his way to the queenside and eliminate
both of White's pawns. What could be more
prosaic than that? Now, you might say, I get
it. What they missed was the move m king Jiwon.
And you can't take the pond because of stalemate.
You would be wrong. Because after F takes
you to, it is not stalemate. You still have
a pawn move. And blackbaced B takes a four
and promotes. We've seen this before. The
actual reason involves using the third concept
after GF three. King f three. White has a
way to make a draw, and hopefully, at this
point, you're already itching to play this
move. You can move your opponent's pawns,
but you can't do it immediately. If you do
it immediately, then you will allow black
to promote his a pawn. So, first, you have
to inch your king close. Kingd one, kingdry
already. You can play a four, but if you want
to be safe, you can play king t one, kingd
three. And you can actually procrastinate
one more move. You, um, can play king c one.
But after kings c three, you already have
to move your opponent's pawns. This is the
move both players, especially hilar, persistent
missed. White plays a four, sacking the pawn.
But if black takes, you know the drill. You've
got corner ponds. Corner ponds never win,
no matter how many of them there are. This
is a dead drop. If black plays king takes
before, then, we get a similar scenario from
to, uh, the Madison study, where white plays
AB five. AB five, and white steps into opposition
with king b two. So this is one of those famous
examples of premature resignation. If I did
that, I don't know, uh, how I would sleep
for the next three weeks. • • • • • Now,
black is no way to avoid this scenario. None.
Because • • • if we fast forward here,
a four, let's say king c three, • • um,
• • takes c one. This is different than,
let's say white plays a four earlier black
and dance around, right? But again, as long
as you avoid playing king b two here, which
hopefully you're not inclined to play, you
can play king b one, you can play king. So
you can do whatever you want to do as long
as you meet king takes b four with the move
king uh, b two. And this is how black mowed
the lawn to create winning chances. But white
could have moved his opponent's pawns at the
right moment in order to salvage the draw.
And this is why I keep a rubenstein needed
to keep exactly one pair of ponds on the center,
uh, because of this scenario. • • Okay,
so on we go to the fourth concept, and I think
this video will also probably be over an hour,
but that's okay. I really, really want to
get through all six of these. • • Hopefully
you're enjoying, • • um, the videos so
far, and hopefully these concepts aren't,
• • uh, • • • too complicated. I
think the examples should be doable. • • • And,
um, our fourth concept is, uh, inducing weaknesses.
Uh, inducing a weakness refers to a type of
pawn breakthrough or trade with the aim of
creating a more accessible weakness or breaking
down a pawn chain. We kind of broached this
topic in the breakthrough video, but I want
to give it a little bit more coverage because
it's super important, and it is the source
of a large number of terrible blunders. This
game is a perfect illustration of that two
strong players. I, uh, think this game was
played in the Czech Republic a couple decades
ago and, uh, it's Black to play in this position
now. Looks like a dead draw. It's a totally
locked up position. Neither king, uh, has
really any entry points. Uh, White doesn't
have any entry points because that D six font
is covering, uh, E Five and C Five and you
can't get rid of it. H Four. H five. That's
totally futile. Black doesn't have to respond
to that either. I assume that both players
probably were kind of already looking at each
other and thinking about where they're going
to go for dinner. And, um, Black decided to
kind of accelerate the process a little bit
and play the move A Five. And, uh, Betox logic
was that he was just going to push the pond
a which to make sure that he locks up the
queen's side entirely. And that's it. We can
chill with the king. There's literally nothing
White can do. But a keen endgame player will
notice something very interesting. The move
a five breaks down, black's own ponche. Now,
the pawn on B Five is undefended. And you
have to pay attention to every undefended
pawn on the board in a pawn endgame because
that pawn is a weak link. And all of a sudden,
after White's next move, black, I assume,
came close to falling out of his share. How
did Stuolik punish his opponent for his incautious
previous move? • • • • • • • • • • • Well,
this one is pretty straightforward, folks.
The move, of course, is A four. This is a
sacrifice in name only. It is because the
pawn is undefended that this move works. Had
Black just played a neutral move, a Four is
still a good try, but Black doesn't have to
react to it. Black and just keep moving back
and forth with his king. Now, after A five,
A four, black does have to react because the
pawn on B Five is hanging. And if Black takes
on A four, then the pawn on C Four becomes
a gaping, massive weakness. White captures
it, steps back with his king, and creates
a past pawn in the center. While Black has,
uh, • nothing that he can do with these,
uh, crippled double pawns in the corner. So
instead, be tok tried king D Seven. But all
the same white plays king E three. There's
no rush to take the pawn. You could take it,
but you can delay king C seven. He brings
his king up to D Four. King. B six. Trade
on. B five. And here comes the second important
moment. Black still has some hope. Black is
clinging onto your life. But hopefully you
also evaluated the waiting move situation
and you saw that White has two waiting moves
and you need to use again and again and again.
You actually need to use both of them to avoid
losing. If you were to play H Four, black
would use up his one waiting move and put
white and Zugzvan, you would have to step
back with your king and allow black's king
to win the D five pawn. Black wins the game.
Again, as you can see, the margin of error
in these pond end games is so low, very often
the difference isn't between, oh, you win
the game if you make the right move. And if
you don't, then, uh, the game is going to
drop. Very often, like, you actually lose
if you don't follow the rules to the letter.
You play h three. Black plays A four, and
now white plays H four, forcing black skin
off of B five. Black loses the C four pawn,
and white won the game after king D three,
king B five. And now, um, I'm not sure, actually.
I think there's a mistake in the notation
says king D two, but king D two is a horrendous
move. My guess is that white actually played
king D four and, uh, black stepped away to
A five. • • White played C four king before,
and now hopefully, you are itching to play
this move. C five. The classic pawn breakthrough,
DC five. Now, where should white's king go?
This is still an important moment. You don't
actually want to go back to D three. If you
do that, you allow black to push C four and
carve out a pathway to C five or break through
with C three. Instead, you want to move the
king as far away from the pawn checks as possible.
You go. King e five. And this pawn race is
easy to calculate. King. B takes B queen and
white wins. Uh, easily. Or if black tries
C here, DC three is check. That's important.
Otherwise black would play A three and the
pawns would promote simultaneously. Here,
white promotes first D seven and white wins.
But all of the trouble started when black
made this unnecessary pawn push, allowing
white to induce the weakness, break down the
remaining pawn chain and move his king into
the critical square. Now, I want to show you
another example of this, uh, concept because
of how crucial it is. And we're going to go
pretty quickly through this one. All right,
let's flip it on. This is one of my favorite
illustrations. It's from one of my games.
And again, I forgot to label this. This is
one of my games from the World Youth Chess
Championship under Twelve, which I did win.
This was back in 2007. But my coach was really
angry at me over this particular game. Now,
in this game, and I think this was round three,
it's white to move. I'm playing white. And
clearly white has a big advantage. We've got
this monster night sitting on D four. But
the big question that white has to answer
here is whether we want to transition into
a pawn and give my opponent, with his last
move offered, a trade of all minor pieces
you know the drill. Pause the video, figure
out whether or not what • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • should
go into
the pawn endgame. And I answered the question
incorrectly. So • • at first glance, the
end game might seem completely winning. You
might say, well, I noticed that I have a past
pawn. It's an outside passer. So, well, I'm
just going to use that pawn as a decoy, and
I'm going to race my king over and eliminate
all of black's pawns. I'm going to chart a
course to the H Seven pawn. But if you actually
calculate the line, you will realize that
even though white's king starts the race first,
blacks got a Ferrari. In reality, white's
weaknesses are just mathematically closer,
uh, than the age seven pawn. So here's what
happens. King before, king takes before, and
hopefully you're able to calculate this. King
takes C five. King C, three. King E six. It's
actually not even fun. Black is already taking
all of white spawns. King H seven, king G
three, and black wins the game. King takes
G six, F four, and black, uh, promotes first
and, uh, • • • • wins the end game.
So this is not an option. Another example
of the natural continuation failure. Now,
what did I miss right? I calculated this line
and assumed that the pawn ending is not worth
going into. • • What I forgot about is
that king takes the five is actually, well,
we can play King takes D Five, or we can play
the critical move in this position. It actually
really doesn't matter. But for the sake of
illustration, uh, we're going to play it here.
Now, in this situation, you should notice
that blacks king is currently shouldered by
white skins in opposition. So you don't technically
have to rush with King takes D Five. So you
might say, uh, ah, well, what if we don't
take unnecessary pawns? What if we go straight
for the H Seven pawn? This also isn't going
to work. Black's going to take the pawn in
F two and then break through with precisely
the pawn that you didn't end up capturing.
Also not an option. What you need, uh, to
employ is the fourth concept. You need to
modify the pawn structure on the king side
such that blacks pawn weaknesses are going
to be more accessible to whiteskin. You need
to create a new weakness. And the way that
you do that is with a brilliant move, G four,
you strike at black's pawn chain, forcing
black into an unresolvable dilemma. If black
takes on G four, then white eliminates both
of these pawns in one fell swoop and gets
a protected passer on E three. This wins the
game on the spot. For example, king the two,
king F four, king E two. And the simplest
is just eliminate the pawn on G four and push
your pawn to promotion. This is nothing, uh,
• to calculate here. Of course, black is
going to ignore white's, uh, G four, and black
is going to like king B Three to prepare to
circumvent, uh, • • • white's king.
But this is where the strategy works to perfection.
After the trade on F Five, hopefully you can
see that there is a new weakness which is
so much more accessible to White's. King f
Five is now undefended, and you easily win
the king race. You go king E five, you start
eating first, and you start eating last. After
king takes E four, white has won all of Black
spawns. King drops into, uh, F four, paving
the way for the EPA to promote. So what I
missed is this brilliant move, G four. I assumed
that you have to take on D five. You can take
on D five and then play G four. This is just
a transposition. • Um, but I think G Four
is even more pure, even more pretty. So, remember,
you don't just have to accept the pawn structure
as it is. You can use your opponents, sometimes
even a sacrifice, in order to shatter, uh,
certain connections in your opponent's pawn
structure and make more weaknesses that you
can then attack. • • Okay, we've got two
more concepts, uh, to get through. Let's try
to do it in about 15, uh, • • minutes.
• • The first of these is, uh, another
notion that we have touched on in the previous
video. And it is the concept, uh, that is
referred to as corresponding squares. • • And
let us, um, pull up the example here, and
I'm going to extend the • • • • definition.
So, the corresponding squares is another concept,
much like mowing the lawn, that is much easier
to simply explain via an example. And I really
struggled with it when I was, uh, kind of
reading it in a book. Uh, it's, like, so technical,
and I was really confused by it. Uh, but the
moment I really paused to think about what
it entails, I realized that it's a pretty
simple concept. So I'll read the definition.
But don't worry too much about taking every
word down. Instead, try to focus on really
understanding this example. I think I'll be
able to explain it in a way that you will
understand. So, corresponding squares, two
squares, will refer to them as square X and
square Y. Any pair, square A six and A six,
for example, are corresponding squares. If
moving the king onto square X forces the opponent
to occupy square Y, that's why they call corresponding
crucially. The defending side must maintain
that order. King steps onto square Y only
after the opposing king steps onto square
X to avoid xuxon, very often, vice versa.
So, if, uh, there's a corresponding pair of
squares, you have to be the second person
if you're defending. If you have square Y,
then you have to wait for your opponent to
step onto square X, and then you step onto
square Y, putting your opponent in Zoog's
Funk. If it was your move, then you would
be in Zoom's Funk. They're also called. Squares
of mutual zoogspan. This is related to mind
squares. And as you see, it's very related
to opposition. So in front of us is another
study. Love this one. This is so nice because
it's so confusing if you don't get the concept.
The moment you get the concept, you can solve
it almost immediately. So this is a study
by German, uh, composer Franz Sackman, uh,
• • from 1913, I think. And White's goal
is to win the game. Now, immediately, even
without calculating anything, you should notice,
uh, the fact that the kings are in distant
opposition. And we saw a few examples of this
in the last video. Distant opposition, I remind
you, is when the kings are staring at each
other and there are three squares, or sometimes
even five squares, uh, between them. So in
order to solve this study, the most effective
method is to draw up all of the corresponding
squares. Now, let's think about • • what
that means in the context of this position.
Well, a much simpler example of what a corresponding
square is comes from a position like this.
Let's say that it's White to move. What are
the corresponding squares if you're playing
Black, actually? Well, there whichever side
you're playing, or it just depends. Uh, a
pair of corresponding squares here, for example,
is E four and E six. I'm going to highlight
White's squares. That, uh, square X in red
and square Y in green. E four and e six. Similarly
d, four and OOH. I forgot. There we go. D
four and d six. Uh, f four and F six. All
of these are corresponding squares. So if
White skink steps onto this square, black
skin has to step onto the corresponding square,
e six and nowhere else. That's the key. You
could have more than one square. • • • That's
a correspondent. But usually corresponding
squares are just one to one. OK, • • um,
king, D four, you can only play the king to
your, uh, respective corresponding square,
d six. Right? So it's really not that complicated.
It's just a square that you want to go to
if your opponent steps onto a certain square.
Now, adding some pawns adds some complexity,
right? • • What is it that Black is trying
to avoid? Well, Black is trying to avoid getting
shouldered. Right. White's very close to shouldering
black teen and just eliminating both of these
sepawns. Let's see if we can draw up the corresponding
squares. Black must keep the opposition here
in order to prevent White from making progress.
So see if you can pause the video and, uh,
• • • • mentally, uh, • • highlight
all of the corresponding squares. And if you
can solve the position, then big kudos to
you. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • All
right, let's pour some more tea, as you guys
think. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • Okay?
• • So to, uh, begin the process of, uh,
annotating this position, • • what happens
if White plays like king d six? Well, our
first set of corresponding squares is obvious.
Black is going to drop back to B six. And
this is the only square that Black can move
on to, should white's king move to D six.
And crucially, if the move orders, if their
order is flipped, if it's Black to move here,
then Black is in Zugzvan. Why is black and
zooswang? Well, because Black has to move
the king and start giving up all of his fonts.
So our first set of corresponding squares
is D six. • • Let's, uh, again, do White
squares and red, black squares and green D
six, B six. Similarly, we can extend the path
to D seven B. If we shift everything to the
right. We just have the same thing except
with longterm opposition. So we have e six,
a six, e seven, e seven, a seven, e eight,
a eight Right. And we can shift things, • • uh,
• to the right. Again, whites king actually
can move to the F file. How does that relate
to the corresponding scores? Well, let's understand
that, right? If white king tries to access
the F file, where does blacks king want to
be? • • Well, uh, if blacks king is on
the, um, A file, when white's king is on the
F file, then whites king can suddenly take
a sharp turn to the left and move on to the
Efilee. Now, if white's king is anywhere on
the E file, all of Black's corresponding squares
are going to be on the afile to, uh, • retain
distant opposition. So the corresponding square
for Black to F six is also B six. It's also
b six, f seven, • • uh, b seven, f eight,
b eight. So that when white's king moves to
the left, blacks king can also move to the
left, maintaining that odd number of squares
between the kings. Remember, if you're confused,
all of this boils down to Black being able
to meet king D eight with king B eight, king
D seven with king B seven, and king D six
with king B six. If we're trying to win this
with White, that's what we're ultimately trying
to prevent Black from doing. • • Now,
the correct first move, • • and I will
tell you the move, and then we'll derive,
uh, the logic. Well, actually, we can derive
the logic immediately. The corresponding square
to F six is B six. Is there a square in White's
vicinity that doesn't have a corresponding
square? Well, not really. Right. F five. The
corresponding square is a five. Right. That's
an interesting wait a second. Black scene
is already on a five. What's the corresponding
square again? Well, it's a square that you
need to move on to only if your opponent has
moved on to square X. So the XY pair is F
five. A ah, five. But Black thing is already
on a five. What did I say? Well, they're squares
of mutual zoo's song. So Black has moved on
to square Y before white has moved on to square
X. And we catch him in the act by playing
the first move king F five. • • If it
was White to move here, then everything would
be in order. But now Black has stepped onto
his corresponding square first. And this is
already Zook's Bong, even if it's not obvious
yet. So if Black plays king ah, A six, then
it's all very easy. King e. Six. White claims
long distance opposition. The game is over.
King a seven. And now that winning technique
is children. You move up to E seven, let's
say king A eight, and push back to D six.
Hopefully this technique you're already very
comfortable with. King B seven and king C
eight completes the shouldering process. And
I'll show the entire line a little bit later.
So, king A six is not resilient. Black has
to try to go king B six. Now we continue to
move, uh, forward on the corresponding squares.
We play king f six. Again, Black wants this
position with White to move, but it's Black
to move. If king C seven, then king E seven.
If king A seven, then also king E seven. If,
uh, • you know, black plays king A six,
then king E six. So whichever way Black goes,
we step onto the corresponding, uh, • • • square.
The most resilient is king B seven. And where's
the corresponding square for, uh, B seven?
Well, it's f seven. So we play king F seven.
• • • And, uh, now Black is officially
busted. Um, let's say Black plays king B eight.
Now, we want to avoid playing king E eight
because this allows Black to reset and shift
the king to the left, right. King a eight.
And now Black has rectified the order. Black,
um, has stepped onto square Y, uh, after White's
has stepped onto square X instead, the correct
move is king E six. I know this is a little
bit technical, but hopefully you can just
see the way that this works. What was the
corresponding square, uh, for E six? Well,
it was a six. And because of the way we've
maneuvered, black can no longer access the
A six square. And therefore, Black gets shouldered
whatever he does. For example. King c eight.
You might say, oh, Black is diagonal opposition.
But no, the corresponding square is A six.
Here we play king D six, king B seven. And
we finally reach our target position. Opposition
shouldering, king B six, king C eight. Let's
say king A six, king C seven. And no stalemate.
White just eliminates both of these pawns.
And White can also go around for the A pawn
if, uh, he wants to as well. So • • you
can convince yourself, if you're still a little
hazy on this, by just playing the moves out
on the board. If Black plays king A seven,
again, this is critical. You don't play king
D seven and allow Black to step onto the corresponding
square. Instead, you play king E seven. And
if king A eight, now you double back to D
six because Black cannot access B six, the
king doesn't move like a knight. King d seven.
Everything always boils down to the situation
with the white king on D seven and the black
king on B seven, and it being black to move.
Finally, • • uh, if black plays king C
seven, then king E seven, and again, king
C eight, shouldering king D six, king B seven,
king D seven. And the game is over. So that
was a bit of a whirlwind, but hopefully you're
able to understand the basic idea in real
life, most corresponding square examples aren't
actually quite as complicated. If you can
understand the notion of mutual zoo's bong,
then you can go A, uh, very, very long way.
But hopefully you're able to see that with
a keen understanding of this concept, you're
able to find a move like Tang F five. Once
again, the way you do this is you chart all
of the corresponding squares, which usually
are squares of distant opposition, right?
And you just try to figure out if you can
see if you can put your opponent in a situation
where he is the first one to step onto a mind
square. This f uh, five. A five is a pair
of corresponding squares, and Black is already
on A five. So we catch them in the act with
the move king F five. Okay? • • And in
the next video, we will have a practice example
that, uh, will allow you to test your understanding
of this. So don't worry too much. I know this
is a lot to swallow. And now we move to our
final concept, which is going to be the notion
of keeping your pawns back. Now, this is similar
to a rule that we discussed in the Pawn Race
video, but it's a little bit more nuanced.
Keep the Pawns Back says that if you are anticipating
a pawn race, keep your weak pawns, the ones
that your opponent will capture, en route
to promoting as far away from your opponent's
king as possible to extend the time it takes
for your opponent to promote. Right. So one
of the Pawn race rules was you want to push
your prospective pastor if you've identified
which pawn, uh, is ultimately going to be
the racer, uh, you want to it's like what's
that term in baseball where they're already
a little bit past the base. You want to push
that pond as far up, uh, as possible. But
there's also the reverse idea, which can be
harder to understand intuitively. You want
to keep your pawns far back, so your opponent
takes as long as possible to take them. Let's,
uh, illustrate that with our final example.
This is a title Tuesday game that I had against
Ariantari. It was a painful game because a
win would have gotten me first place. And
with just a couple of seconds on my clock,
I failed to practice what I preached. So,
in this position, it is white to move let's
pause the video for one last time and see
if you can decode the winning process. • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • • Okay,
so what makes this example really hard is
that there is a super, super tempting move
in this position. And that tempting move is
of course, C five check creating a past pawn.
And after BCBC, hopefully you're able to understand
that this is a pawn race in the making. White
is going to eliminate these two pawns and
promote the F pawn. Black is going to try
to promote the A Pon by eliminating whites
C and A pawns. So let's calculate. Black plays
King C six. Well, let's go. White plays king
V. Well, after king takes V, king takes F
five. You'll remember that you don't have
to engage in the pawn race. King C four loses,
king takes C four, and white wins the race.
But unfortunately, hopefully you were able
to spot that black can actually double back
to D four. And there is nothing that white
can do here. If you try to go after the H
pawn, then black will go after the Fawn and
only white can lose the game. So this is why
C five fails concretely, but you could say,
wait a second, I don't have to go king E five.
I'm going to push my pawn up to a four, force
black's king back and then go around and take
all of black's pawns. That was my logic as
well. Remember, I had 3 seconds on the clock.
But what I fail to factor in is that I am
actually helping Black by moving the A pawn
up and moving the Cpawn up and saving Black
crucial temp instead of moving the king back,
which loses a lot of time. Black's only move
here is F four. Kudos, if you found this move
now, let the pawn race begin. King 64. King
65 takes King b four. I moved my king to the
side. He took F four • • • • here,
here, here. And the pawns promote simultaneously,
to my great disappointment. Now the game is
not overwhelmed, can take on H Ah five. And
I think this is winning theoretically, uh,
• • but it is an incredibly hard position
to win in a practical game. And Arian, with
some very accurate defense, was able to catch
me in a perpetual check. So this is clearly
not the smooth way to win the game. The mistake
that is hidden in this sequence is that the
move C five check, as natural as it is, is
actually wrong because it brings upon up to
black on a golden platter. What you should
try to do is keep the C pawn on C four to
make Black waste another uh, • tempo to
play king C five and King takes C four rather
than King takes C five and king B four. That's
two moves. King c five takes C four. B four
is three moves. How do we do that? Well, once
you know the idea the execution should be
pretty straightforward. You start by trading
on a five, and now we play the move a four.
Inevitably, you have to play a four. Otherwise
you're not going to induce Zoo's Bong, right?
You have to move one of the pawns closer,
but you keep the Cpawn on C four. • • Black
plays King C six. If instead Black plays King
E Six, then you push C five, because now Black
has to waste more time getting to the pawn
and White wins the race very easily. • • So
instead, Black plays King C six. And now you
have saved the crucial tempo. We had this
exact position with the pawn on C five, with
the pawn on C four. That's one tempo, and
that's all that you need. King takes out five,
King takes C four. Notice that if Black tries
to follow the rule of not taking unnecessary
pawns here, you can win in several different
ways. But the most elegant is just a force
Black to take the pawn by playing C Five.
And here Black wastes, uh, even more moves.
So king takes c. Four is forced takes. Here
f ah. Four. Here f ah. Five. And it's easy
to assure yourself that indeed, White promotes
first by a single tempo and then is able to
easily blockade Black spawn from a one. So,
uh, the 6th Rule, a, uh, continuation of a
pawn race concept, is when you're anticipating
a pawn race, you want to move your perspective
pastor up as far as it'll go. Now, it's not
possible to do that here because F Two is
immobilized by Black's pawns. But the reverse
of that is you want to keep your pawns as
inaccessible to your opponent's King as possible,
which often means actually avoiding, uh, pushing
them, as tempting as it may appear, • • that,
ladies and gentlemen, concludes the six advanced
topics that I had planned for this video.
Once again, the video came out quite a bit
longer than I expected, uh, • • it to
be. But I really hope that, uh, the pace wasn't
too frenetic. I hope that you were able to
benefit from this, you were able to follow
the definitions. Uh, before I close off, I'm
just going to project all of them on the screen
here. I'm going to expand • • this, uh,
• view, and I'm going to give you all of
these concepts, • uh, in one view so that
you can, uh, take them down or copy them down
as you wish. We, uh, talked about the waiting
loop sacrifice, generating an additional waiting
move. Mowing the lawn, clearing a path to
a set of pawns, moving your opponent's pawns.
That's a strategic sacrifice in order to shift
pawns in a favorable direction, often onto
the corner file, uh, where they are at their
worst, inducing weaknesses, sacking or trading
in order to transform the pawn structure in
your favor. Corresponding squares. Confusing
sounding term, but actually pretty straightforward.
• • • • Any XY square, where if your
opponent steps onto square X. You have to
step onto square Y in that order to avoid
zoom's bond and keeping the pawn back. Keeping
the pawns back. In a pawn race, you actually
often want to avoid pushing pawns forward
to make it as long as possible for your opponent
to take all of your pawns. And on m that note,
ladies and gentlemen, I'm closing off for
today. The next video is going to be a practicum.
Um, I'm going to give you ten test positions.
We're going to test all of, uh, these concepts,
and I think it's going to be a really fun
one. Hope you enjoyed watching. Thank you,
everybody, for the amazing feedback on this
series. It's made it so rewarding and so much
fun, uh, for me to make. Uh, and, uh, we'll
keep carrying on. There's so many more endgames
to explore after bond endgames, but on that
note, happy end gameplay, ladies and gentlemen,
thank you so much again for watching over
an hour. I know it's a long time, and I'll
see you in the next video. Bye. • • • • •